what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be breaking
down the Flash trailer that showed at
the Super Bowl yesterday and we're
specifically going to be talking about
how this film is going to reset the DCU
James gonna confirm this when he
revealed part of chapter one for the new
upcoming DCU and we've even gotten word
of another Batman possibly appearing in
this movie no not Michael Keaton no not
Ben Affleck of course we saw both of
them in this trailer but we are talking
about another Batman which we'll talk
about at the end because it's kind of a
spoiler now in this trailer we can
really see that DC is taking a lot from
the flashpoint storyline in the
flashpoint storyline The Flash goes back
in time to save his mother in which he
is successful and this actually ties
into the very beginning scenes that we
have in this trailer and the voice over
from Michael Keaton's Batman Batman is
asking him you can go anywhere you can
travel through time you can go to other
timelines you can go to other universes
you can literally run through the
Multiverse so why are you here in in
this universe the universe where Michael
Keaton is Batman when he could literally
be anywhere he wanted to and his reply
is because this is the one where my mom
lives and in the very opening scene we
actually see him arrive at his old house
we see tears in his eyes because he
realizes his mother is alive in that
house right there in front of him in
another scene we see him standing in
front of the house again but his younger
self who's a child runs out this is most
likely when his mother dies this could
be a moment where he goes back in time
and fails to save her but based off of
what he tells Michael Keaton's Batman
this is the one where my mother lives it
seems like eventually he will go on to
save his mother just like he does in the
comics however there are major
repercussions that come from doing that
and that's kind of one of the bigger
points for Barry in the flashpoint
storyline he learns that he can't change
this because it causes so much chaos and
destruction that eventually he lets his
mother go and doesn't go back in time to
save her and it looks like this story is
going to be following that exact path in
this trailer there we see two different
Batmans and to simplify it what's most
likely Happening Here is that current
Berry is with Ben Affleck's Batman this
is The Flash who has his powers who is
well established we're assuming that
since this is kind of connected to the
old DC EU that this of course is
happening after the Justice League and
it seems like Ben Affleck's Bruce Wayne
is still kind of the Flash's Mentor so
it seems like he's actually having a
conversation with Bruce Wayne because of
course he is a genius as well about him
going back in time to try and save his
mother or just simply going back in time
what cause and effect would that have on
their universe or any other universe and
this is where Ben Affleck's Batman says
if you were to go into the past you have
no idea what the consequences would be
basically setting up this entire story
of the movie but we obviously see that
Barry thinks of it a little bit
differently he says but Bruce I could
fix things and Bruce Wayne adds you
could also destroy everything and
obviously from what we know from what
this trailer has shown us Barry does go
back in time and creates a ton of chaos
but before he goes back in time in the
beginning of the movie he still is
technically in that Justice League
universe that's why we see Ben Affleck's
Batman and that's where we get a few of
these scenes with atflect and some of
his new gear like the bat cycle now I
saw a lot of people talking about this
online stating that it's actually
Christian Bales The Dark Knight spat
cycle but it's not as you can see up
front it definitely has two different
tires so this is bat Fleck on this
Batman motorcycle which is based off of
the White Knight and he has a new suit
we finally get the blue and gray suit in
live action so we'll get a scene in the
beginning with bat flag and the Flash we
also see the flash ring on Barry's hand
most likely given to him by Bruce Wayne
of course and then everything is kind of
going to hit the fan and the Flash is
basically going to break time now from
here he finds himself in Michael
Keaton's universe and he runs into his
self in that universe who doesn't seem
to have his flash Powers yet he seems
very confused when Barry grabs him he
has no idea what's going on and in this
trailer I think we we both see him try
to get his powers for the first time and
fail but then actually get his powers
this scene right here where we see both
Barry Allen's lightning blue Lightning
going through one of them into the other
it looks like they're trying to recreate
the experiment that originally gave
flash his powers however I'm pretty sure
this fails but we'll go over where it
doesn't fail in just a bit but from here
when Barry finds himself in this new
universe the first thing that he wants
to do besides find himself is go find
Batman and this is exactly what he does
in the comics like in this trailer in
the comics the berry in that Universe
had a different origin story so did not
have his powers yet so they do recreate
the experiment so here Barry is going to
go and try to find Batman bafflect was
his mentor and took care of him and was
in charge of the Justice League in their
universe so of course when he finds
himself in this new timeline or Universe
he wants to find Batman and this is
where we find ourselves at Wayne Manor
now in the comics one of the
consequences of The Flash going back in
time and saving his mother is that the
events that happened were Bruce Wayne's
parents died were kind of reversed Bruce
Wayne actually died his father Thomas
Wayne went on to become Batman and his
mother actually went on to become the
Joker so in the flashpoint comic
storyline when he goes to Wayne Manor in
this other Universe he is actually met
by Thomas Wayne and Thomas Wayne
immediately starts to attack him before
the flash finally convinces him that
he's actually a time traveler and from
here we hear Barry Allen say that he
messed up everything he says this can't
be happening I completely broke the
Universe I created a world with no
meta-humans and from here we see The
Return of General Zod in this new
timeline that Barry has created by going
back in time to save his mother General
Zod and the other kryptonians arrive at
Earth but Superman is not there to stop
them so Zod wins and this is just one
way that Barry has messed up the
universe now of course he goes to
Michael Keaton's Batman asking for help
he tells him that he screwed up
everything and then Keaton's Batman even
says want some help we see the bat cave
and and it looks absolutely fantastic
Michael Keaton back as Batman in the
suit again is amazing but it looks like
he hasn't really gone out as Batman in a
very long time when Barry flips on the
lights the switches are covered in
spiderwebs the Batmobile has a tarp over
it the Batwing looks like it's been
sitting there for a very long time so it
might have been about 30 years since the
last time Michael Keaton's Bruce Wayne
was actually Batman however they do show
us an incredible fight scene showing us
that he's still got it however long it's
been whether 30 years 10 years five two
years he's still got it now they realize
they probably can't defeat Zod so what
do they do well it seems like Bruce
Wayne has heard of a type of metahuman
Supergirl they didn't get Superman in
this universe but they did get Supergirl
now in the flashpoint comics in this
other Universe Superman did not land in
Kansas and the government captured him
and kept him underground since Superman
and Supergirl get their powers from the
Sun this basically rendered Superman
almost powerless so he couldn't break
out of the prison where they were
holding him it looks like this is going
to be somewhat of the same story except
instead of Superman it's super girl so
of course what are the two berries and
Batman going to do they're gonna go
break out Supergirl so she can help
defeat Zod now of course as we see in
the trailer this does end up happening
they run into some trouble and Barry is
like what do we do Batman and that's
where Batman is like uh Supergirl's
gonna do most of it just try not to get
yourself killed let's try not to die
here and we actually see Supergirl
literally saving Batman's life he's
about to take a bullet to the face while
trying to punch this guy but the guy
fires off the round however super go
comes in smashes the bullet and then
smashes the guy saving Batman's life so
they basically break her out to the
surface where she can absorb the
sunlight and get back to full strength
and from here this is where they're
gonna go take on Zod however the other
Barry does need his powers now it's
clear they try to recreate the
experiment and the one scene that we
have in the trailer to give him his
powers and this could work but if it
doesn't I think they showed us another
scene where he could be getting his
powers for real it could be the scene
where we see the bat wing up in the air
getting struck by lightning the
lightning runs down what seems to be a
metal cable and this could be going into
the other Berry to give him his powers
in fact right after we see the scene it
shows Barry with lightning blue
Lightning surging through him now the
reason one flash has red lightning and
the other has blue is pretty much just
so we can differentiate them on screen
however there could be another reason
there were some toy leaks that came out
not too long ago and these toy leaks
showed us that there's going to be a
young Barry Allen who we have here but
there's also going to be a dark Flash
and some people are theorizing that this
younger Barry Allen that we see here in
this trailer could go on to become the
dark flash in the movie because yes Zod
is going to be one of the villains
however he is not going to be the main
villain apparently the main villain is
supposed to be the dark flash however
dark flash is supposed to be older so
they could simply introduce him later on
as a completely different character it
doesn't necessarily mean the younger
Barry Allen will turn into dark flash
but once the younger Berry finally gets
his powers it's time for all of them to
go and fight Zod it shows us a little
bit of the scene of the two flashes
fighting together we see Supergirl who
does tell us in this trailer that her
name is Cara she is Cara zor L that's
her Kryptonian name just like Superman's
name is Kal-El we see her in her full
Supergirl suit and it looks absolutely
amazing and from here we can assume that
they beat Zod but in the end it looks
like Barry is still going to have to
accept the fact that he can't go back in
time and change things unfortunately
much like in the comics that's probably
going to mean that he can't save his
mother from dying now from this point on
in this video we are going to get into a
little bit of spoiler talk so if you're
trying to avoid spoilers for the movie
now's your chance to click away now if
you're still here recently we have heard
some reports from some insiders like my
time to shine hello that George
Clooney's Batman is going to be in this
film possibly in the post-credits scene
so what is most likely going to happen
here is that Barry is going to kind of
fix things but not not completely fix
things and this will cause the reset of
the DC EU going into the DCU this will
also explain how some characters will
remain like Aquaman but other characters
will be completely reset like Batman now
James Gunn announced that the new Batman
movie a part of chapter 1 in the new DC
Universe is going to be the Brave and
the Bold And in the comics this
storyline involves an older Batman one
that is close to retiring so there is a
possibility that they could use George
Clooney's Batman for the Brave and the
Bold however I'm not really thinking
that's the best idea I definitely think
recasting a new Batman would be the way
to go here however there is no guarantee
that whatever Universe The Flash ends up
at at the end of the movie is going to
be the main universe that he stays in so
George Clooney being Batman at the end
of this movie could simply be to show
Barry Allen that hey he still did change
some things and hey it's a different
Universe now because like I said James
Gunn did confirm that this movie the end
of it will reset the universe so let us
know your thoughts and theories down
below if you caught anything very
specific or hidden about this trailer be
sure to let us know in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the future videos you can also follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof